I've lived and worked in some
very diverse countries around the world.
I was born in India,
but I grew up in Iran.
I remember I was about eight years old,
as a child in Iran,
with my family watching
the beautiful festival of Nowruz.
Nowruz is celebrated usually at night
with families gathered around a bonfire.
They share food. They sing songs.
Sometimes they even jump
over the fire for good luck.
And I remember how deeply that reminded me
of another festival called Lohri,
celebrated all the way over in India,
also with families gathered
around a bonfire, sharing food,
singing songs together.
Even an eight-year-old child can tell
how profoundly similar
those two events look
in two sets of countries
that are culturally so different.
Like a kind of hidden connection.
As an adult, I’ve spent
20 years of my life
studying consumers all over the world.
What they feel, what they believe in
and how they act upon those beliefs
when they buy things.
And of course, a big part of my job
is to truly understand
the diversity that exists in the world.
But maybe because of my upbringing,
what truly fascinates me
is when we find these hidden connections,
these secret similarities between people
where you least expect them.
Today I want to share
some of that magic with you,
bring you into my world.
And we are going to go
do some detective work
on the world's consumers together.
Stay with me, because I think
there's a message of hope
in here for all of us.
Before we start, let's have a think
about how companies,
businesses are organized today,
how they operate today.
Most commonly, companies are organized
by regions, subregions.
That's how supply chains,
organizations are set up.
And if it's not geographies,
then it's some other thumb rule.
It could be linked
to some common historic period.
So, for example,
the Commonwealth countries.
It could be linked
to common religious roots.
For example, I've been a part
of a lot of discussions
on the halal economy.
It could be something, anything
that allows us to put the world
into neat little boxes,
neat little clusters, that explain
why people are similar or different.
But I realized that
when you study the consumers
and when you go deep,
it's interesting how none of that applies.
How wrong some of that thinking can be.
Let me show you.
About a year ago,
a team of us set out to understand
how consumers exercise choice
around the world.
In this process, we interacted
with over 40,000 consumers
in 18 countries around the world.
We asked them many, many questions
about their mindsets to start with.
So, for example, your worldview,
your personal philosophy.
Do you feel optimistic?
Do you have a love for technology?
Do you care about peer approval?
Things like that.
But we also tried to study
some very specific consumer behavior.
So, for example, what do you look for
when you buy a snack
or you buy a beverage or luxury products?
What needs are you trying to fulfill?
As you can imagine,
there was a ton of data
for the geek insiders
to go crazy with, right?
I love that type of data.
So anyway, we take all that data,
and we start to draw correlations.
We start running all these analyses.
And we come up with this kind
of a proximity analysis.
Quite simply, every green dot
represents people of a particular country.
The closer the green dot is
to the map in the middle,
the more similar the mindsets are
for those two sets of countries.
And the further the dot from the map,
the more diverse the mindsets
for those countries.
It's as simple as that.
So of course, when you do this for the US,
you can see that the Canadians,
the people of the UK and the Australians
are very similar in mindsets
to the Americans.
Now we had been studying
consumers for a long time
and the whole team fully expected
that we were going to see
a lot of clusters come through,
based on some of those thumb rules
that I talked about earlier.
So imagine our surprise.
We run this data
and we find very little clustering
based on any of those thumb rules.
We didn't, for example,
find an Asian culture cluster.
We didn't find a European cluster.
Nothing like it.
In fact, we found 90-percent correlation
between the Americans and the Australians.
Two sets of people on the literal
opposite ends of the world.
Can you imagine that? How amazing is that?
And this is a big deal, by the way,
because businesses, companies
operate, govern themselves,
entirely on the basis of these clusters
that we found didn't even exist.
And believe me, we tested
a bunch of thumb rules.
And the interesting part was
that it was not as if
you can find new thumb rules
to replace the old ones that don't work.
The answer was
kind of technical, actually.
It was: just don't do it.
Resist the urge to find any kind
of thumb rules to explain the world.
These are only propagating stereotypes.
So then we said, OK,
if all these thumb rules don't work,
how do you make sense of all the diversity
that we see around us?
How do we put some patterns?
How do we understand it?
So then we started to study the specific
consumer behavior I talked about.
What do you look for
when you buy insurance?
What do you need when you buy beverages?
When you buy apparel, cars,
things like that?
And here we found something
that was even more profound, I think.
Let me show you.
So this time I'm using China
as the base market.
Again, as before,
green dots, overall mindsets.
Now you can see immediately
when you see this chart
that the Chinese are such
a unique group of consumers.
The inner circle is empty.
The second circle is also empty.
Then you start to see India, Mexico,
a couple of other markets.
But the correlation shows
not a lot of similarity
between the Chinese
and those group of customers.
So clearly, China stands apart.
Very unique group of consumers.
But we notice Japan on the top left here.
The Japanese are so diverse
from the Chinese.
And yet I know so many businesses
that put Japan and China
as neighboring countries
in the North Asia cluster.
That's so common.
It's so wrong.
Anyway, I digress.
I get very excited with this stuff.
(Laughter)
So then, coming back to the point,
on top of it, we overlaid
these black dots.
The black dots are now
the needs when you snack.
So what motivates you
when you reach out for a snack?
That's the black dots.
And when we did that and we studied it,
we found a hidden connection.
I don't know if you can already see it,
but I'm going to circle it for you.
We found that the Indonesians,
the Saudi Arabians
and consumers of the UAE
snack in very similar ways to the Chinese.
Let's think about it for a second.
These are Muslim countries.
Very different culture,
very different background to the Chinese.
And yet they snack is similar ways.
How cool is that? Right?
And similar how?
Well, for first,
in all of these countries,
snacking is a moment of social indulgence.
It's something you do as a group.
So people snack in groups,
they share the snacks.
They often buy a hot snack that they
purchase from a hawker or a food court.
Somebody prepares it fresh for them.
The quality is not guaranteed.
It's very important.
They snack in similar ways.
In contrast, the Americans,
over on the top left,
snack very differently.
Americans snack alone.
(Laughter)
They don't share their snacks.
It's often at their desk in a package,
very different from
the rest of the countries.
Now I wonder, do the Chinese
and the Indonesians know
that they snack similarly?
I seriously doubt that.
But what a beautifully
human thing to know, right?
And valuable, too.
Imagine what a Chinese snacking company
can do with this insight.
A lot, right?
Let's take you to another one.
I'll show you another one.
Still staying with China.
The green dots are still the mindsets,
but this time the black dots
are how you buy cars,
what you look for when you buy
an automotive product.
Now again, I guess you guys
are getting better with this now.
But here's the hidden connections.
We found -- and I'll name a few countries,
there's quite a few similar to China,
but two that I'll call out.
South Africans and Nigerians buy cars
with similar motivations as the Chinese.
In all these countries,
your car, your ride, is a status symbol.
It tells your peer group who you are.
So your car needs to show
you’ve arrived in life,
and it's a very external
point of influence.
What will others think
if I drive this particular vehicle?
In contrast, look at
the Germans at the bottom.
Very different,
very internal, very personal.
Your car has to be fun to drive.
That's very, very important.
And who blames them, right?
With those beautiful autobahns.
Lovely roads, no speed limits.
Of course you want your car
to be a fun ride, right?
But wait, look at the French now.
The French are very different
from the Germans.
They want their cars to be reliable
to navigate narrow roads.
So there you have it.
Two countries, France and Germany,
neighboring countries, European countries,
very different motivations.
And then a couple of African countries
similar to the Chinese
in the way they buy cars.
No clustering, no business group
will ever put these countries together.
But maybe a road trip from Beijing
to Lagos is just going to do the trick.
Who knows?
Anyway, one more, last one.
Indulge me, just to rub it in.
So here's another one.
We're coming back to the US this time.
Again, green is the mindset,
but the black this time
is how you buy clothing, apparel.
Now remember we talked about
how the Americans and the Canadians
are very similar in mindsets earlier?
And we also talked about,
you know -- of course,
they are closely connected
neighbors as well.
Now, however, they don’t buy
apparel the same way.
The Americans buy things
that are on-trend.
They're looking to indulge.
The Canadians look for utility.
They are looking for apparel
that can be good for adventure,
and a love of outdoor sports
is critical here.
But controversially,
the Russians buy apparel
in very similar way to the Americans,
also looking for something
that’s on-trend,
also looking to indulge.
Now to say that there've been tensions
between these two countries
is a serious understatement, right?
And yet they have
this one beautiful connection.
They have one thing in common.
What a lovely idea. Right?
Now I could go on and on.
I showed you just a few examples today.
But we found this over and over again.
Category by category.
Country pair by country pair.
We saw this in all kinds of things,
like luxury, beverages,
insurance, you name it.
We found these connections everywhere.
And I don't mean any of this to belittle
the massive, beautiful diversity
that we see in consumers around us.
That's exactly why consumers
are such an important study
for people like me.
But I think this work shows
that mankind is connected
in a profound way that we never imagined.
It also shows that these connections
defy any stereotypes
that you and I or businesses
can come up with.
These are patterns
where you least expect them.
And in these connections, of course,
there are commercial opportunities
for marketeers
who can embrace this insight.
Of course, it's commercially valuable.
But today, I want to go a step further,
if you permit me.
I think in these connections,
there's also a message of hope
for the world.
We live in a world that has globalized
for more than four decades,
and yet we're getting torn apart,
shaped by the geopolitics of our time.
Countries are falling into blocs.
Fault lines are appearing everywhere.
I'm not a specialist in geopolitics.
I'm just a student of the consumer.
But when I look at this data
and I think about it,
if only people knew that we are similar
in the most profound ways
in some of our most everyday activities,
in the way we sip a cup of coffee,
taste a snack, try on a new outfit
or test drive a car,
how beautiful would that be?
Maybe if we knew that,
we would also learn to understand
and empathize with each other.
It's a lovely thought to reflect on
maybe with your next cup of coffee.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)